bring in florida republican senator
marco rubio senator thanks for being
here thanks brett
let's start with ukraine uh today you
came out of this briefing and you told
reporters this is dangerous potentially
catastrophic and could escalate yeah how
serious is this at this moment well
there's two things right there's the
invasion of ukraine which would be
probably deeply problematic because it
would be returning to a world in which
powerful countries can just take over
their neighbors right i mean that's the
claim russia makes about eastern europe
and that's ultimately the claim that
china is making about asia that all
these states are supposed to be vassal
states that are tributary states to them
so that would be a big development but
the second thing to keep in mind in all
this
is the potential for miscalculation and
escalation you've got uh the largest
russian military operations going on
exercises in 35 or 40 years you've got
nato countries on a heightened level of
military readiness and they're right
close to each other and so there's
always that potential we've already seen
some pretty aggressive russian actions
in terms of navigating close to ships
and things of this nature and some of
the reporting including the brits so
there's a lot to be concerned about and
then the notion of cyber warfare if
putin launches cyber warfare we've never
had a cyber war we don't know how
quickly that escalates what that can
become so there's a lot to worry about
here in terms of this thing escalating
beyond ukraine well should americans be
concerned about cyber retaliation in
some way shape or form from russia if
for example critical infrastructure that
sort of thing if if the russians uh
respond that way i mean i think
cyber vulnerabilities is something
people are aware of we've seen it
because of cyber crime we've seen it
because of ransomware and so there's
always the concern that a nation-state
with advanced cyber capabilities a
russia today a china tomorrow could
launch some attacks the problem with
cyber is these are not precise weapons
they're blunt instruments and sometimes
when you cyber attack a system you think
the outcome and the impact is going to
be one thing and it turns out to be
something far more serious so then the
other country has to respond and you
start escalating no one's ever conducted
this cyber warfare before there's not
really a doctrine or rules of the road
or anything that govern it so i think we
have to have two goals in mind there has
to be real consequences for an invasion
of ukraine and at the same time we have
to ensure that we do not allow this to
escalate beyond ukraine into something
broader how has this administration
handled this in your opinion what about
these
you know coming out publicly and sharing
what they know about possible false flag
operations and when maybe putin might
move what do you think of that
well i think time will tell about
whether that worked or not look if
there's not an invasion and putin is
dissuaded from invading then that would
be a great outcome and i think that's
one way to go about it if
it doesn't happen that way then people
have to
have a different opinion about it my
view of it is that when something this
big on that involves global and national
security is engaged
i think the political accountability is
going to come later if mistakes were
made i think right now though we need to
be focused on two things as i said there
has to be consequences not american
troops we're not going to go fight send
americans to fight in ukraine but there
has to be real consequences for an
invasion but we also have to make sure
we manage this very carefully so it
doesn't escalate into something far more
dangerous and and potentially
catastrophic we don't want to see that
two more quick things you just heard the
report on the durham investigation and
what you've heard about that so far
your thoughts this is a big deal i mean
it it's shocking to me that this is not
receiving more coverage in the press i
don't think any of the sunday shows
mentioned it but what we're talking
about here is not simply this you know
the probe using data scientists to make
up a story or links to between trump and
russia but the white house apparently
there was a private company that had a
contract to manage servers for the
president of the united states and the
white house and they were sharing
information to help build a narrative
for a political operation and you know
why the if this is all proven true it
would be one of the biggest political
scandals in american history it would be
a crime no doubt about it and it would
tell you why these people think they can
get away with it they think they can get
away with it because the media will not
report on it if this was the other way
if this was a story about how the trump
campaign had hired some data experts and
others to go out there and do this to a
president clinton this would be like we
wouldn't be able to talk about anything
else around here yeah senator we're
covering it extensively we're going to
ask a democrat about it just after the
break but here's what they say why are
republicans seemingly not as alarmed
about president trump's handling of
documents compared to worries about
hillary clinton's emails both former
national security adviser sandy berger
former cia director john deutsch slapped
with criminal penalties for mishandling
national security documents we know
they're the 15 boxes down in mar-a-lago
there's allegations of flushing
documents down the toilet in the oval
office that the former president has
denied
how do you answer that well first of all
i don't know what's true and what's not
because they've made up so many stories
about donald trump over the years that i
mean things that i just knew were flat
out untrue but nowadays in mainstream
media you just need one source to smear
donald trump maybe you don't even need
that so it's hard to tell anymore what
really happened and what didn't the
documents that were in mar-a-lago by all
accounts were turned over look if the
process wasn't followed there then that
there needs to be something that happens
about that it's not a crime i don't
believe
but the stuff about flushing paper down
the toilet who knows if that's even true
these people i mean at this point i've
seen at least a dozen things said about
trump that turned out to be complete
lies let me just make it up and and some
of the media just run with it it's true
i've seen books with things in there
that i know were not true and and
they're widely reported as established
facts so that's that's why it's so
difficult to take anything they say
seriously but what i'm talking about
with what happened with clinton that's
not some reporter that's not some story
in the new york times
that's a federal pleading in federal
court
senator rubio thank you very much for
your time and
this is intense time we appreciate you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else